hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Mark appliers Manic
Monday Mail mania mash things so anyway
um as you can see the pile of boxes is
pretty large but not as bad as its I
think I think this is about as bad as
it's ever been so this is pretty much a
maximum anyway so there's almost like
the difference is there's almost zero
letters there's very few letters that
people actually said to me I think
people wanted to send me boxes in the
hopes that I open it so I've already
pre-cut everything just to save a little
bit of time so that I can try to get
through as many of these as possible I'm
not sure someone pointed out that
because all the boxes seem to have
letters in them and I read those then
maybe I should just keep open boxes and
those letters um we'll see how it goes
I'll play it by ear we'll see how far we
get down this but let's get to it no
time to waste
big one let's do a big one first this
one was from Express Mail I had to sign
for it personally so it better be worth
it whoever this from goodbye on the
inside that's you do not have to read
the letter on camera just read the list
of what's in the box okay
what is in the box there is a companion
cube for you to keep or give away
minecraft tools and weapons for you to
keep her giveaway on minecraft objects
animals a Wade Bob and me in Minecraft
giveaway
um pony version of me - definitely
giveaway I'm just kidding people have
been like there'd been brony words in my
comments I'm like I don't care about
bronies I'm not one I never will be one
but that doesn't mean that I actually
hate them so just calm down everybody
people like their own thing and a
special friend for my collection of
Batman pimp cup a spongebob cup an
awesome belt buckle all the giveaway or
key so let's see these things
this is definitely in depth airs a
spongebob cup of kidding
stuffing stuffing lots of stuffing what
the hell
whoo it wasn't kidding it's a Batman
pimp Cup
yeah haha that's that's kind of awesome
it's made of glass - so I should have
been a bit more careful unwrapping that
I didn't know that it was made of glass
so gently set that over there and there
was a lot more minecraft stuff oh maybe
it was just pictures and there's Captain
Awesome I'm gonna wear that every day
it's a belt buckle so I can have a
Captain Awesome belt buckle thank you so
much
who is that from Jessica and Mike Mason
so thank you so much oh I guess that's
me as a pony done all right so let's
zoom in here ah they were all hang on
they're all oh my god wow this must it
oh my god this must have taken a while I
got to get it all out of here first
Wow look at this okay there's there's
what
there's the pony yeah these are all be
darting there are a lot of these so this
must have taken quite some time there's
a really cool Slenderman that's actually
really well done I'm impressed
thank you so much and then there's a lot
of there's my head in Minecraft there's
Wade stupid head in Minecraft where's
Bob Bob's Dexter head in Minecraft
his is coolest by the way and then
there's dnt da right bowtie okay and
then there's tools um I think these are
diamond I'm not sure finding this is
really cool there's a lot of cool stuff
here there's even hearts those a lot of
work put into this stove that's why you
did Express Mail and finally the
companion cube
hey yeah yeah okay all right so I will
set all those back in the box for
safekeeping and I won't get later so oh
no
but being fell off of something I don't
know what though sorry it was bound to
happen
so a bead fell off of something but I
thought that was bubble wrap still in
there I just dropped him into the bottom
of the bottom of the box and they just
kind of shattered no they did purchase
one
they are just fine so thank you so much
and thanks for the pony one thanks I
guess
thanks okay anyway so thank you to mark
apart from the Lani airs the long years
haha I just punch Bob karate Worf -
sponge orfs - spongebob Worf pants
spongebob Worf square - I don't know but
that's cool thank you so much and then
there's a Minecraft bracelet both in
green and pink and then there is a box
of cheez-its and a letter
lets us read the letter good oh god hate
letters I don't have my letter opener
here and I don't want to use my giant
knife yeah oh my god no no you stupid
letter I'm sorry
I'll read it dear markiplier I sincerely
thank you for all the nice stuff you do
your for your fans I also want to thank
you for the money that you are raising
for charity you have raised more than
31-thousand actually we've raised over
48,000 now for charity
holy crap that's a lot of money raised
and again I would like to thank you for
that also he drew you were on the
Cincinnati news I was on the Cincinnati
news you can check it out in my videos
just look up markiplier on the news if
you want to find that video and probably
once in a lifetime opportunity for you
well says I'm never going to be on the
news again well fine
let's see I have
so I I have somewhere this package for
you some it's hard to read is torn in
half sorry what I want to do is stuff in
picture wait no that's a sign the
picture and then send it back to that I
can't do that sorry but I'm reading it
kind of thank you I just want to say
thank you for what you've done for
everyone keep up the good work alright
bye bye let's see
sincerely Parker Lonnie err okay so
that's over there and then there's
cheese's there's a box of cheese's in
there that's all there is you can see it
I'm not lying there's a box of Jesus in
it so thank you hmm oh my god people
wrap it up so much okay what have we got
there's a t-shirt the like a boss
t-shirt with the Facebook like thumbs up
though thank you for that who is this
from this is from it does not say dammit
another one that doesn't say and people
are going crazy with the wrap ups the
old duct tape look moustache duct tape I
really need duct tape I was gonna go buy
some but now I have much - duct tape so
that's even better thank you and then
there's more mustaches and the nurse
well I don't these Plast old plastic ice
cubes
oh you freeze these and they're in fruit
shape so that's pretty cool thank you so
much and then there's one more thing uh
oh god don't eat a wrapper like this
you're making my life a living hell
ah there we go
what is it what is it oh it's a picture
it's a fan art of me in a nice frame
it's a mannequin people haven't brought
up the mannequins in a long time Bhosle
because i haven't been dealing with
mannequins in quite some time i haven't
played a game with a mannequin in it in
like forever so now that's good memory
on you and you didn't smell mannequin
correctly but either way still pretty
cool and
put that back in there is there a letter
a name of something I do not see
anything okay I don't see anything but
whoever this was from thank you so much
all right said that there right there oh
right yes oh this one says free free
free GLA from Heather - Heather less
thank you so much other man you guys
just doing incredible job but I'm hardly
able to get through any of them just
because you're there making these boxes
so involved right oh my god it's the
same package egg oh did you all go to a
meeting on the Howard up s market buyer
off with your packaging meeting Oh God
just Joshin all right there's a letter
right here on top to mark fischbach
let's see all right I'm a recent
subscriber in a very impressed with your
work I'm happy to say that I'm proud of
you for not only making awesome videos
but as well as well as put forth the
dedication and time to put on
fundraisers like many other people I
have lost Oh No period like many other
people I have lost a family member to
cancer sadly I wasn't able to donate for
the Alzheimer's disease fundraiser due
to being tight on money but I hope to
donate for the next one I was able to
watch a portion of your livestream video
and I'll have you know I had double
fists in the air when I saw you playing
quake 3 arena I love that game that game
is awesome I hope you liked the gifts I
made whenever I feel like Shh I can look
forward to you and your videos to feel
better so this is AB least I could do
I wish I could do more for you like you
have a good heart and an amazing
personality thanks AVI all warm bubbly I
love you I have good friendship feelings
towards you as well and may the
squirrels be with you warm regards
Heather don't read this part aloud in
the video up
all right so what do we got here that oh
it's more paintings okay that's why
there was the extensive amounts of bowl
wrap and tape there's another nice
framed picture of Slendy man thank you
so much this has always watches and then
there's another framed picture of a
dragon a really cool dragon by the way
well done I don't like it all these
these frames are like really nice okay
and oh my god I'm gonna kill myself ah
mother of God okay there we go
a really really nice drawing of me
that's actually really well done close
enough close enough thank you but that's
awesome thank you so much for all this
and oh my god
bubble wrap everywhere my life's a
living hell
we're already 10 minutes in and I've
barely gotten through three boxes you
don't need a pocket that's so much I'm
gonna hurry I'll uh I'll read this
before you look at the rest of the
package okay ah see though I've only
known you about you for a month you've
made my life a thousand times more
awesome and show me that it's possible
to make life so much better for so many
people just by doing something as simple
as playing video games your videos and
fundraiser standard charity livestreams
are a massive inspiration to me keep
working to keep working on my own
channel in hopes of one day being able
to share my experiences with a massive
audience as you maybe even do some
fundraising myself who knows I
absolutely love your spotlights and
playthrough of indie games enclosed is a
little something to help broaden your
range in which you can reach out to
indie developers and shed light on games
that likely wouldn't have ever been
noticed trust me you'll likely use it
more than I ever would sincerely Adam
Hawke explody thing game
yeah okay let's see what this is what is
this seems to be some HDMI cables of
sorts oh oh no it's an Elgato Game
Capture I already have one I'm so sorry
I have one I've recorded a couple Xbox
games already and I have this exact
model a Jason Hawk um if you want me to
give this back let me know because this
is an expensive device I know how
expensive this is I bought it so if you
want me to send this back just let me
know I'll keep it in the box
I've got your return address here just
send me an e-mail or something with
explicit from Jason cog so let me know I
already have this thank you so much for
the other thought but really I do I have
it I just don't use it so thank you
anyway all right good we do funny with
it okay from the other side nice small
one let's Doge out the bubble wrap
it's a Slendy man shot glass I won't
even bother taking it out it's a slight
amount shot glass I'm Lulu bad and okay
that was in there's some paperwork here
a free Android or Blackberry smartphone
yeah uh CafePress now here wheel hi mark
I've been watching your videos ever
since I came across her slender
elementary video back in November and I
was hooked I think it's great you use
your audience for good raising money for
charity here's something to give you a
chuckle take care from Randi stare
pioneers productions thing thank you so
much for the shot glass I've always
wanted a shot glass collection from the
ones that I've gotten so far with the
moustache one and this lending one in a
couple others this is I've got a thermo
collection finally so thank you so much
oh my god not packing peanuts it's even
worse
why what the wait a minute oh god he's
getting everywhere there's a plant in
here as an actual looks like a the
bamboo plant is it live is this real oh
my god it's real that's really real and
there's other stuff in here too but I'm
being very careful not to get packing
peanuts everywhere oh it's a it's a it's
a it's a it's a pot for the plant I
don't know I'll bump I'll plant this
I'll grow it so thank you so much for
that and there's probably a letter
buried in here underneath all of the
packing peanuts I'm not seeing anything
I really am NOT all there there's some
hanger oh it's just a packing slip um
there we go thank you so much for your
order oh all right then that's just from
the company so I don't know where um
anything else is but thank you so much
from Ray 9gb ray 9gb
that's what it says on the box oh thank
you so much other with four anyway all
right I will find that later
I'm trying to move as quickly without
being in a big rush all right we got a
letter here dear mark hey my name is
Chris I don't know if you remember me
but I met you at the San Diego Comic Con
last year I was the Asian guy who talked
to you about suggesting to sell t-shirts
and a bunch of other nonsense you also
got to meet my sister Arlene it was
great meeting you
we still think you're an awesome
entertainer I continue to look forward
to your vids daily especially as for
stressful days from work it surprised me
in one of your playthroughs that you
loved the comedian Brian Regan he is
also one of my favorite comedians Brian
Regan is amazing anyone needs to see
Brian Regan alright he is all any way to
keep this little short here are some
items that hopefully will assist you in
future drunk minecraft videos hopefully
you don't have them yet keep up the good
work and as always take care take lock
and care take care of the lock that you
may have if you have luck take it care
for it hey get it Brian Regan hey
everyone from Chris ah I only met like
five people from comic-con last year
because I only had like only five oh
it's Rubik's Cube coasters I don't think
they're actually solvable as a puzzle
but they're definitely stackable that's
really cool thank you so much there
anything else in here there's some sort
of a box let's see what's in it a bomb
oh no it's all modest
it's a Minecraft pickaxe bottle opener
bottle opener oh my god you're so cool
look at that thing whoa
Oh Philip look at this thing it's made
of metal or stone at least it's made out
of something hard and heavy uh-huh
but anyway look it's a little pickaxe
how'd you get dirty Gator No - oh god
okay Turner go okay
control yourself Mona play okay so
that's really cool thank you so much for
that I'll definitely use that that's
like awesome
I'll write that up putting that aside
thank you so much Chris you're the bomb
ha suck it tend to go I took your phrase
lead me first from Britney cowls let's
see what you got hopefully I won't rip
your letter in half
let's see la la la la la la la la la la
la de mark I first want to start off and
tell you how great your channel isn't
that it's so great the charity work you
do with it
yours is the first I've ever seen to do
that so to commemorate just how awesome
you are
I've made you your own personal action
figure I started making this for you as
soon as I found out about your p.o box
in the purple box you will find your
weapons of mass destruction please enjoy
the gift and keep it close by for
inspiration and as always I will see you
in the next video I didn't actually draw
this cool slender guy I found him on
boop boop all right let's see what you
got that's C let's see what's gonna give
me it's whoa no way
that's so cool I look like a Ken doll I
probably have a Ken doll huh look at
that
ah just wash - don't be afraid of warf
warf dicen gonna morph - should find it
- thank you so much for you cat
markiplier doll that's really good know
something you know something in a purple
box your weapon of mass destruction now
is it whoa oh whoa is this weapon him ah
ah it's a mini box it Jesus I don't need
any better of oxygens it and my sand and
some sunglasses mini sunglasses for my
doll that's really cool well done on
that that is this that is probably
that's really unique gift so thank you
so much for that alright ah see what you
are oh you're a battery some sort of
cookie of some sort
umm fruit by the foot yeah uh an orange
mustache oh and I'll let her yeah
alright let's see what's in the letter a
read first whoops
mah mah bad how about fault term Akbar I
love your shows they are very funny if
you didn't notice I sent you a pocket
battery with a pop off lid oh you can
disguise your safe with the durcell
battery some of my friends call me a
loser because they think you're so lame
hi well they're losers for thinking that
I'm lame cuz I'm super cool right
everybody another screen cap opportunity
okay alright whenever I'm sad your
videos cheer me up so as a sign of my
appreciation I hope you can be friends
with some of your fans from Let's Plays
of charity dreams you are awesome with
funny fails to eight or nine pages you
are hilarious
just for your courage pretend you mash
more victories than yamimash I did kinda
if you don't like the gift don't use it
put it in a giveaway section or you
can't write back I understand
to get you something bigger don't laugh
at what I just wrote as I was saying my
dad is a rich pharmacist what did you
say that I was reading it right here
right in front of me I didn't okay
anyone thank you so the battery is
actually pop up ah it's a fake Oh
battery oh hi
tall oh and died that's actually pretty
clever well done on that hmm really cool
well thank you so much
um now is who's that from Leon
Anthony maker thank you so much Leon you
are the bomb
ha okay god packaging material is
literally everywhere all right we got
something here
sorry oh it's another shot glass from is
that the Swedish coat of arms Norway
Norway that's the Norwegian coat of arms
I love the my friend fans from Norwegian
way and there's no note from there
straight from Amazon so thank you all
from Norway I'm going to assume that all
of Norway I will see helping me out with
that
and so I I do not need to do to either
thank you no from Norway next rock trip
true someone got me a safety box cutter
because they were probably afraid of me
opening everything on camera with a
knife let's see hey Mark I figured this
would make help open boxes and such more
safer grammar by the way I don't know if
you remember me i donated 6.66 dollars
during a livestream you and Wade were
freaked out for a second I have since
just been donating $10 increments
sincerely are Damian name
then on the name of some guy from Devil
May Cry 29 Damian I don't know really
but thank you so much Jamie Nike or
anything actually in these newspapers
I think I think this was it okay so
thank you so much for the box cutter I'm
actually gonna bring that out and have
it right here because my alternative is
Barry is currently buried under painting
so I'm gonna need it so thank you making
good time on these boxes I'm actually
pretty impressed see what we can do Oh
what is this it's a cheese it's cracker
container for like lunch boxes I'm
guessing for like so you can measure out
a bunch of cheese it's so you don't have
to play like a ziploc or something and
this is from Amazon from late Rachel
lamb thing thank you so much for the
teeth okay
I mean yeah I used to I used to like
cheez-its but I mean people have been
sending me so much cheese it's not like
I like cheez-its
I'm not insane I'm gonna get so fat
eating all these cheese's huh man so
thank you so much kind of falling apart
but there's lotsa this is actually from
this is from the UK one of my fans over
in the UK land okay I thought I would
send you lots of British food so if you
even try to play the amputee game again
you'll be ready I was going to send you
some tea bags but it might get pulled
into customs and I want you to get this
partial here on parcel here on time just
in case some things that meant I hope
that it was right in the you can't get
any of these things in America but I'm
not so sure because sometimes Ethernet
can lie but here it is anyway enjoy
you're gonna get so fat from Vicki so
thank you so much it's also another
letter in here
of some sort it's a long one I may save
this one for later let me just plant it
first
oh boy yep it is a long one
um it's just uh let's see I will read
this in private later I read the other
one and this is pretty long so I will
get to it later but it will be read do
not worry about that let's see what we
got here we got Hobnobs how much more
British could you get then Hobnobs
ah ah just a Prakash I'm gonna make fun
of everything in this box
foxes ah clearly a British celebration
of pompous misen a sin headed head in a
student ish yeah Oh arrow meant bubbles
I think these are in America they have
their the arrow thing I don't get the
air thing you're getting less chocolate
basically they put air in it so that
there's there's less chocolate there you
get the elk to delight of tasting air
ma'am oh that air is so good I love it
both and more arrow bubbles thank you
Joe and then cat a galaxy that's
actually the set looks exactly like
another type of chocolate so it's
probably marketed in under another name
here in America so thank you for that
seriously I'm gonna get so fat here it's
unbelievable jaffa cakes by McVitie's Oh
jaffa cakes for tea and crumpets ah ah
Tian oh by the way some people are
wondering why I look at just to the left
of the camera not to the camera
coz I can see myself here and I'm not
I'm not I'm not professional enough to
look at the camera all the time so I got
my camera up here that I could see right
here and so yeah I'll try look at the
camera okay jaffa cakes uh
and we got offices crunch screams seem
to be in a bit of crumbly state but yeah
rainbow drop oh oh
breakfast yeah I'm gonna play with
yamimash later dude I'm a prepping for
all my mocking that I'm gonna make it
feed from breast not pretty
oh and lastly there are fingers Oh kind
of a stupid name for a chocolatey
chocolate fingers aah aah all gasp
room-to-room drop your fingers oh oh oh
okay just ignore me I'm stupid American
ignore me I'm stupid American with
Swedish accent stupid half asian
american all murica don't matter all
Merc thank you so much oh that one took
a while oh boy some of these boxes just
take a long time to get through it's
serious okay
hello we got here do my hog I'm this is
this really well done it's written in
numb
killed calligraphy I'm one of your
subscribers since early 30,000 I love
your humor you're a wonderful person
thank you for making me laugh every day
you chew me up my entire life by just
being silly and thank you for playing
all the scare games since I'm a big
whiny baby when it comes to such things
but I love watching when someone plays
them happy Easter afterwards and I hope
that you that my super awesome pink
mustache chocolate sugar cookie survived
a long way this must be from Britain
land - huh it took me five hours to make
them I suck at baking and I used gloves
while making them and kept everything
super clean blues my favorite color and
that's why one of the hotend shaped
cookies is blue stay the way you are
mark much love from Germany ah ah hi
no that's Scott oh oh not that Germany
and I oh oh what you did I'm going to
Scottish anyway Oh lil devil not see
that coming haha that's an octave bum JK
I'm half American not racist at all just
low block here
Shawny oh you're a girl haha Shawny slow
miles for 19 years
nickname red hello holder evil that was
Monty Python I went all over the place
without one so I hope I mocked everyone
in the world in that one so everyone
who's watching this should feel offended
ha ha ha all right we got a chocolate on
amboy game on you root cube pony and
then we got some ooh these are the
cookies at the [ __ ] I won't pull all
these out but these are though the pink
and white mustache cookies thank you so
much for those and there's a bunch of
those in there and then there's this
blue heart which we're talking about in
the video so thank you so much for your
all the way from Germany
Wow a long way to go alright rubba not
make a good time oh this one's heavy
why is one too heavy more room for the
bomb Oh wha it's a it's the world's
largest gummy bear
I wonder what so this thing is freaking
a heavy this has got to be like I mean
it's about five pounds this thing is
five pounds of gummy oh my god or it's
still a bomb and when I bite into it's
gonna be an explosion of flavor just
like the meat blowing in my mouth okay -
thank you so much who is that from a
gift no from Richard throw enjoy your
gift and yes we're all trying to get you
so fat thank you guys so much
you don't understand how much I love
thank you so much I will actually much
on that little bit later I'm trying to
get in shape
oh no fat and troubling the chubby in
the midsection here
Oh Oh what's this we have some hot cocoa
from Canada ah ah
Yatta Yatta Yatta heya kanaday tim
horton's as it's a good place for coffee
and gala day also sorry about having the
packaging good like that I don't know if
you could all hop the yahoodi okay is
everyone offended yet cuz my objective
is get everyone offended is everyone
offended have I missed anyone let me
know if I missed anyone in the comments
I know I missed someone
alright so thank you so much for the cob
or the cocoa that is from Tim Hortons
USA oh they must have ordered it
directly from Tim Hortons cuz I don't
think Tim Hortons would have sent me
cocoa by themself and they won't ever do
it again now that I'm making fun of them
op de yada you told EA
that's how whose line is the fine whose
lines anyway they did a bit where they
had to speak Canadian and so drew Carey
opens with haughty yadda yadda yadda
yadda
and somehow that was Canadian so that is
how I imagine all Canadians talk even
though
a very good Canadian friend and I make
fun of them all the time for it so
anyway thank you um now what's this it's
on a Pokeball I think so I'm not good
with bulking on um and thing I'll or /
I'm gonna call this a floor / oops sorry
I almost stopped my recording but I did
not so I got a Bloor / and a pokeball
sorry I'm losing the camera
blorp her in a Pokeball and please read
off camera please okay I think this I
can read on here is a Mario mushroom
oh if you look at it like this yeah
Oh OHS Wow I did not catch on to that at
all that is amazing I made for you sorry
if the bottom it looks a little smushed
this was the first one that I could make
that look like it's supposed to
I hope you all you like it all the same
I know you said that you didn't watch Bo
c'mon but I also made a pokeball for you
go throw it at weight I don't want to
catch weight
yeah wait is it sounds like a terrible
disease to have okay enjoy
Robin Bartlett thank you so much you are
the best ink
okay Oh honest her daughter hello I just
think that the hello and enjoy my
muscles for a few seconds while I stand
here oh my god packaging whoa I love
sour right pyrite worms gummy worms I'm
tempted to eat them on camera a button
that says I'll cook today yay and then
there's something at the bottom here
there's a lot of little stuff in this a
moustache keychain thingy pink and
sparkly very sparkly by the by there is
a moustache lanyard pink by the by open
care you're still enjoying all the gun
show yeah I thought you would yeah yeah
time for yoga with markiplier
ah they are shot glasses but what type I
do not know I will open one and that's
all open cuz it's a son of a [ __ ]
packaging again God hurry in your ways
it is a toxic hazard shot glass which
says zombie virus zombie virus so thank
you so much for that I will keep the
other one for safekeeping there a letter
some there once again I do not see one
there's oh that I found something else
peanut M&Ms gonna make myself haha I do
not see one but this is from a McCleary
a McCleary so thank you so much a
McCleary
you are awesome I'll bite Oh Rajee lay
sorry I misspelled your name from TMI
Siri it's okay I probably butchered your
name too so let's see it some I'm sorry
there's a drawing on the box
no no if you can see that it's like a
Griffin with a mustache
so anyway oh not packing peanuts not
packing peanuts mark I'm a fan of your
videos thanks to a friend who showed me
some of your happy wheels stuff you have
such talent for entertainment I hope you
continue doing what you love here is
something special for your terror and
our enjoyment Tim OTT says buy one item
I did not make but thought of you
immediately when I saw it enjoy okay
oh man there's a lot of stuff in this
okay
flashlight lulululu lunch flare let's
get a little J Bay JJ Abrams up in here
ok thank you so much for that what is in
here oh my god ah is so Betty
why do you do this to me why is there a
box in a box covered in beer King
peanuts it's wrapped in duct tape and
barking beam us do you want better get
off
okay that was actually much easy it's
just game okay let's use our fancy new
box cutter try to get this out of here
I'd like buried in stuff this always
happens and it takes me like two days to
clean everything up I'm buried in
packaging material and boxes and I have
to go through and sort it for hours and
hours Adams kind of alright so anyway
let's just get this open here don't even
know how yeah guess that's gonna do it
no it's not where the hell am I gonna
open you this is an unbelievably well
wrapped box congratulations you made it
very hard for me to open oh my god oh my
god oh my god why is it glued down there
why would it Big Love there there's no
other way to open it besides there and
it's like super glued oh god ow my
finger got it
why you guys are killing me you guys are
killing me
yes serious killing me whoo all right
okay
now we have a little a [ __ ] Ehrman
figure looks like he's made out of
either clay or some sort of porcelain
with a little sign on it he's adorable
thank you so much for this Oh whoo all
right how is hard that was really rough
to open huh I am beat I am tired
but we've got to keep moving forward oh
look okay
so anyway ooh what do we got what do we
got
ah another portable turret thing one of
20 so I'm gonna put this I've got my
other one still here in the box so this
one was
- OH oh that might be the same one I
have to open it open seat I'll open it
later and figure it out but thank you so
much for that we also have Aperture
Science portal - ice cube tray which I
actually have one of these already but I
can always use more thank you so much
for that and there's also I love
Futurama it's a planet express t-shirt
I love Futurama Futurama is the best and
oh no oh no it's a pickaxe bottle opener
ha ha I've got you now No
oh my oh my oh my oh my oh you're all
mine border okay thank you so much for
that do use there anything else in here
there's sort of a note thingy there's a
sticker a monkey sticker and then dear
mark hope you enjoy all the awesome
stuff
you deserve it this is all from
ThinkGeek by the way so there's a lot of
stuff I've gotten from thinking so thank
you guys so much for that Oh Sarah
Carter Sarah Carter thank you so much
Sarah I will put this over here right
oh my god it's box ception we got more
band-aids here bandages for my fingers
which are fine now and well when not if
when I cut myself again I will close but
we got another box in a box here which I
did love please don't be another box in
here I will lose my mind
if there's another box in this box I
will be I don't know what I'll do
good that's not another box in the box
I'm just kidding it's chairs chairs
miniature chairs you know I haven't
referenced chairs in a while just cuz
you know I got I got tired of it but
some people still pick up on it so thank
you so much for the chairs I really do
appreciate that and that is from was
that from lugar that Kimberly McDonald
there we go Kimberly McDonald thank you
so much for the chair I haven't I
haven't actually gone many III kind of
slowed down on doing amnesia custom
stories just cuz you know I've done in a
while and I'm waiting for a machine for
pigs to come out and I imagine when a
machine for pigs come out they're gonna
be a lot more incredible custom stories
to play alright we're actually almost
done with the boxes bluff some time for
some letters here well probably the
envelopes because there are boxers and
then there's envelopes there's not many
letters themselves but there are a lot
of envelopes Oh what have we got here we
got a poster some sort and we got it
open okay all right look at that some
wow it's some fan art hey thank you so
much me in cilenti's woods I want to be
the guy guide an amnesia rein unfair
Mario just a bunch of Let's Plays at I
done by a cool a blur question who's
better me I mean as markiplier Beauty
pipe me me always me it's me I'm the
greatest of all yeah I love mom yummy I
should ask and in case people don't know
I have nothing but respect for PewDiePie
I don't know why everyone thinks that I
hate him I do not I have nothing but
respect for that guy so I I don't know
why people badmouth him so much he's
actually a pretty cool guy so anyway so
thank you so much for the fan art I will
put this away in a very private location
just rolling it back
just rolling it back and we got it
rolled wheat we looking at me like that
we're gonna be like that
what oh oh you're so dirty minded oh
that's disgusting how dare you all right
what we got next up it's a mug wrapped
in ten bajillion layers of bubble wrap I
don't think that was your fault
thank you Mitchell Schmitz Mitchell
Smith Smith sniffles Mitchell wait
Mitchell
sure shoulders I was way off
hey look it's got it's me it's me and
it's got a bunch of my catchphrases on
it
jiggle-jiggle-jiggle butcher whoo so bro
to grow you dick huh yep those are
exactly as I remember them I remember
saying those thank you so much that is
awesome Thank You Mitchell I will drink
my morning water I don't drink coffee um
I only really drink water so thank you
so much for that right
no time for that got a move on what is
that good there
all right what do we got here this is
from summing Li song summing Li song som
en g ly s Ong summing Lee song so what
do we got we got a t-shirt of sorts ooh
this looks good
how do I get you with my brew bottle
okay
it has ooh I like it it's a oh that's so
cool
that is so cool I mean this isn't like
an official drunk minecraft t-shirt but
it might as well be that is awesome it's
a loading please wait and there's a mug
of beer being drunk down that is so cool
and I wish I was bigger I wish it was a
bigger design here but that's that's
like really cool thank you so much for
this oh man that's like awesome I love
it and there's something in here wrapped
in bubble wrap
spend a lot of time building what is
inside please be careful well let's see
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's an actual 3d
bead art thing I've never seen a 3d one
before that is so cool thank you so much
that's like awesome look at that look at
that little guy does his head spin no
and then there's a grass walk that's so
cool thank you so much man that is
awesome and they're actually it's
actually correct because it's a block
width and the head is basically the same
size as a block so how cool is that you
even got the size right thank you so
much for that you are awesome you are
I don't thank you so much ah perfect for
drunk minecraft it's perfect
there's only one box left we're actually
gonna get through all the boxes in my
normally scheduled time so we did good
all right please read first hello mark
my name is Travis Sullivan although I
may not be your biggest fan I have
always been I've been watching your
videos for about two weeks now I love
playing video games but ever since I
found you in Yami mashes videos which
we're gonna make another video today I
have found or I haven't been playing
games for a while I never would have
thought that watching someone else play
a game would be more entertaining than
me playing a game myself you and
yamimash are really funny I love your
random horror compilations keep up the
good work
I also bought you a gift an easy button
it isn't any button you can put this
right next to your computer so anytime
you have an easy movement moment in one
of your games which I know you do cuz
you're so great I am you can press the
easy button or maybe you are just having
a hard time then maybe the easy button
will change your luck may the power of
Slenderman be with woo
I would the power Slenderman be with me
and maybe his nipples oh okay
may the power of Sonny's nipples be with
you alright so and there is a an easy
button a button that was easy that was
easy
that was easy that was easy
that was easy that was easy
that was easy that was easy
that was easy alright thank you so much
that's awesome and we're actually
through the boxes so let's get to some
of the others oh wait no there are tubes
here there are some big stuff that I
will get to I will get to them in just a
second just a hot like that I suppose oh
my god itself are in there gotta get out
oh he came right out okay what have we
got huh a nice piece of fan art look at
look at the loo it's me Slenderman
forcing there standing behind me
Hey look a note doo doo doo doo doo doo
class album game goes black hey you're
welcome for that reenactment that'll
that that reenactment only cost you 199
Joe please loss play 199 to your local
retailer your fur fur thank you so much
this was from stormy Thomas stormy
Thomas
all right that's actually very have a
bit there's on some envelopes here that
are you know pretty hefty they probably
got some important stuff in here so
let's just keep keep it going and
hopefully my computer won't crash for
anything destroy the video make all this
useless baby baby baby baby baby oh it's
wrapped in Hello Kitty everyone knows I
love Hello Kitty
there's a box in an envelope Oh what
push it's a box of Lucky Charms but I'm
guessing it was repurposed
rubadoux we're having it what have we
got here
have we got there is stuff there's stuff
in here areas stuff there's cookies hey
guys
moustache cookies that's so cool
Worf - cookies Wow we'll wash - Long
Wharf docks going love these cookies
wash that guy love him to death
what guy good luck okay thank you so
much for the cookie this is problem oh
my goodness there's some burnt paper art
look it's like burnt paper smells like
cookies oh there's a lot of stuff here
so I'll read the first paragraph Hale
markiplier congratulations on two
hundred and seventy thousand subscribers
almost 300,000 now we are a group of
Oberlin College students Ohio neighbors
who have been watching your channel grow
since last fall we just wanted to tell
you how much your channel means to us we
made you wharfs a shaped sugar cookies
to celebrate your glorious triumphs in
joy and there's from Adam gluten
jacqueline megger kamek in Z Saxton
Michael pons
Myles Allen and they are all part of the
invisible college we hope your career
continues as props firstly as it has
been so far you are a gentleman and a
scholar keep up the good work so thank
you so much for this I will read the
rest of that later cuz it's very nice
very nicely done very delicate it's
actually getting
I'm gonna have to vacuum my room I'm
buried in boxes okay let's see what we
got here
come on now come on up get up y'all all
right what do we got whoa whoa whoa some
belt mom fell bran flakes
everyone loves Brantley it was a mini
painting of the amiga monster grunt or
as Mangum inks calls him mr. face which
i think is a pretty appropriate name
manga mix was one of the first people to
do a let's play of amnesia that got any
sort of popularity so I think her name
deserves to stick yeah oh my goodness
it's really well done I'm gonna show it
to you but it's really disliked look
wanna say I've ever seen oh my god this
is amazing
understand it's really cool really well
done look at that that is like amazingly
well done good job on that that is well
well done thank you so much all right
markiplier I'm so glad you've opened a
peel box as I can finally send my
gratitude in a physical form I'm sure
you've been inundated with mail and I'm
sorry to add to the pile great youtuber
doing great things and there are many
others as kind-hearted out there there
aren't too many others I'm sure you can
see from the steers the sheer amount of
gifts and letters just how many people
are thankful for your existence it's
been fantastic watching your channel
grow and I'm sure it will continue
expanding you're a fantastic guy Marc
and we all look forward to your videos
with this is some fan art and I hope you
like it I'm an inspiring tattoo artist
just about to go to art college they
name may not be fantastic but it's the
best I can do
Erin pool 17 years old from South
England if this is the best you can do
at 17 you are climbing mock warbird hard
your glog argent sword look at the
detail and anatomically horriffic yes
that's really cool so thank you so much
ah you that I'm just I'm really
impressed by that that's thank you so
much that was really cool what what what
that was I was I was just like thank you
so much hahaha it's a pun I must ask you
a question oh yeah oh ha ha so funny
there's no funny okay Drago funny yeah
yet put your funny nerds nerds hungry
nothin e today all I've been doing is
recording videos everything this is why
I'm videos o5 cuz your first thing I eat
today is candy mMmmm
hmm hey Fisher
I don't really it's candy much huh
readers you take out the items please
read whole time thing and it binds the
gifts and it is not as long as you think
these ones out of paper read on camera
don't tell me what to do' dear mark my
name is Hayley and I just wanted to say
how much I love you all tonic friendship
feelings and your videos in this package
letter thing I have put in a lot of
things that are personal to me first I
of my musical poster which is on Friday
the 26th and by the time you get this it
most likely will be over I hope it goes
well I am nervous second is one of my
favorite songs by chameleon circuit
doctor what why band they are amazing
reading dramatic voice you need to watch
Dexter who it is um a Doctor Who
Oh doctor who no I will not it is
emerging watch the Steven Moffat
episodes seasons 1 to 7 point 5 the most
recent and aren't very good not written
by Moffat third is a picture of
toothless I from Wow there's there is
quite a lot here um you said it wasn't
going to take as long but there's a lot
of stuff here I want to get to other
stuff so I'm just gonna up flip through
it um there's a there's a bunny and a
doggie a bunny and a doggie oh there's a
big ol eyeball there
and oh my god there's there's there's a
poet there's like basically all this is
really a lot of stuff but um this is the
musical poster that you thought about
that she's gonna do good luck it still
has yet to go you're not done yet
good luck on it I hope you do well I
will read all of this afterwards but I
just can't do it
right now and there's a friendship
thingy there's a there's a friendship
bracelet and a friendship necklace I'm
guessing so thank you for that um
there's another friendship bracelet a
lot of friendship stuff let's see um see
celebration welcome home from Walt
Disney there's a bunch of fortune
cookies there's a lot of stuff in here
I'm guessing it would all be explained
if I could read through it but I just
don't have time to I'm actually I'm
getting pretty close to the end so I
want to get like other people to be able
to see this is a compromise I have to
make I have to either you know if I have
to give some people all the attention
err and then some people none or try to
give everyone as much attention as
possible and it's just hard to do so I
will move on at this afterwards
you got one more one more remember this
is maybe two more maybe two maybe two
the box cutter comes in handy you're
right what have we got here oh my oh
it's another one with a lot of little
things in it oh my that's up
it is old this little hair clip don't I
look fabulous
don't I look fabulous tell me I'm
beautiful tell me tell me I'm beautiful
tell ya tell me I'm in ok sorry so what
else have we got
let's see mark it's me
Gwyn Oh 1 2 - I love you platonic
friendship feelings and we have please
wear this if the need arises here's the
tinderbox use it wisely
mmm I fixed this literally so much stuff
stuffed into this one I'm trying to get
like a letter that I could read it's a
poem and there's a drawing I I don't see
it like an individual letter that it can
read so I will let's see I will just try
to show off what is else in this there's
some popsicle sticks
and ah here we go I think I finally
found it mark there's now my second
piece of fan mail to you the last one
was one with the over overly decorated
envelope which you sadly did not put on
your last video me and a friend Gwen
this time put the letters in a box to
guarantee that you would read this on
your video Rox we're talking about this
is not a box let's see after all you did
say that you would open every box on
video like most video fangirls would I
took advantage of that you're taking
advantage of me
how dare you how dare you let's see oh
and my last letter I sent with drawing
of the markiplier horse I was not
referring to you as a brony my two
favorite things just happened to be you
and horses also Minecraft but it would
be difficult to draw a markiplier
Minecraft horse no one nice and blocky
oh let me name some of my favorite
things about you favorite coat you don't
have to look both ways when you got swag
your looks tell me I'm beautiful
tell me not really so I wrote of aha ok
your looks
Lowell your humor your generosity I
would name more but it would fill up the
page I almost forgot when you say that
you don't know how you actually save
people's lives and make their life
better I know people who are depressed
or recently had a loved one pass away
you make them smile you make them happy
most people might think that think what
is life with no laughter or smiles you
make people happy enough to keep their
life to live I their their life to live
I hope that cleared something up for you
on how you make people's lives better
this note is starting to get long I love
writing and as always I'll talk to you
in the next letter bye bye lol love
Emily lemon lemon lemon Cleveland
Cleveland Pleven plum and blue Bentley
sorry there's some stuff on the back
tube so so
doodads and little things so thank you
so much for the letter I look beautiful
gorgeous even I think you - I look I
think I look so ready just like a pretty
little bar why thank you so much and we
are officially all out of time so that
will do it for this week's markiplier
male Mash Monday menagerie of madness so
thank you all so much for watching
remember the peel box is in there below
I got through all the boxes this time I
will read the letters off camera
everything will be read I deal with it
takes me it's an all-day experience but
I will get do it I will get to it for
you guys who you are guys are worth it
so sincerely from the bottom of my heart
I'm swimming in gifts it's the greatest
feeling of the world also like I've just
thrown a good packaging material - so
girl less packaging next time so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye